this week we've had a series of reports
on a botched police raid in chicago
we need to warn you again that this
video is extremely
upsetting 12 male police officers
picture this burst into the wrong
apartment and detained an innocent woman
who was changing at the time so she was
buck naked when the police arrived
that was nearly two years ago and none
of them has been just
disciplined now chicago mayor lori
lightfoot says
she wants change and accountability she
spoke to cbs chicago investigative
reporter dave cevini
who broke this story dave good morning
to you i can't wait to hear what the
mayor has to say about this now
yeah good morning gail for two years
we've been exposing a pattern of
bad raids in chicago anjanette young is
just one of more than 50
bad raids we've uncovered we've spoken
to the mayor about this before
but gail today she's promising change
when i see something like this i take
action chicago mayor lori lightfoot says
she is calling for immediate change
after watching these tapes of angenette
young
and even though this matter happened in
february of 19
is coming to light on my watch so i own
it young stood
naked before heavily armed chicago
police officers who had just
burst into her home during a raid that
should have never
happened men broke into your home
cuffed you bound you and videotaped you
naked
that sexual assault day is what that is
in any other context that's sexual
assault
mayor lightfoot said the video was
especially painful to watch as a black
woman
the trauma that she
was experiencing
it was impossible for me not to put
myself in her place
when you see the reaction from the mayor
she told me this was a painful week for
her
her saying that this has been the
hardest week for her
it's been two years for me in a press
conference thursday afternoon mayor
lightfoot said she wants to sit down
with young
but young and her attorney don't believe
it is sincere she sent that email
immediately prior to her walking into
that press conference
and then telling everyone that she's
requested a meeting
and so that was the first time we'd ever
heard that
lightfoot admitted on thursday she was
wrong when she said her administration
didn't tell her about young's case until
this week acknowledging she was told in
november of 2019
but she said she doesn't remember that
you know people saw this video in your
administration
does that make you wonder why you didn't
know about it
no it makes me angry that i didn't know
about it it makes me angry
that decisive action wasn't taken
if she didn't see my video dave you were
you've been reporting on this for two
years our investigation began months
before lightfoot took office
that's when i met a then nine-year-old
peter mendez who told his story of
police wrongly raiding his home
and pointing guns at him and his family
just a saddest moment
after mayor lightfoot took office in
2019 she told me she wanted wrong raids
and mistreatment of children to stop
salter says his client story shows
not much has changed this was an active
attempt
to cover these things up and that's a
refrain
in chicago that is all too familiar
now late thursday the city released more
body camera videos of angenet young's
raid
more videos than they ever knew existed
including a body camera
from the first officer through the door
with a rifle
pointed at her now the city says they're
no longer going to go after
angenette young for sanctions for
releasing the video but they do say
they're still going after the lawyer
there's a hearing on this
on tuesday tony dave you said at the top
of the story
that you've looked at 50 cases of what
you call bad raids
what do they have in common
well they all have pretty much one thing
in common police believe a confidential
informant
or a john doe informant without ever
checking it out without ever checking
out the address
you just can't take an informant by
their word you have to independently
verify it
yeah it's about the standards in this
case dave savini for us again this
morning dave thank you very much
so powerful stories very powerful i'd be
very curious to see what dave thinks
about what the mayor is saying now
you know when i talked to antoinette
young she said to me i supported the
mayor i told everyone to vote for the
mayor and quite frankly i feel very let
down
and betrayed by the mayor at this point
it'll be very interesting to see
if the two of them eventually have a
conversation because she's still reeling
from it and what strikes me and what
dave said is that
once again like in the brianna taylor
case it goes back to the warrant
how did the warrant get generated on
what information
and then the police themselves are put
in a tough situation if they're given
bad information if mayor lightfoot is
saying change now is she going to change
that